we've only had one video on our channel
get demonetized because of violence but
i would really like to push the limits
and see how far we can take this before
getting demonetized
hopefully with this video we find a
youtube line
i'm an ex particles demented genius i
have this feeling of great joy
inhalation but
it's coming from the fact that i'm
watching a person getting exploded
[Music]
it's so satisfying to watch
but okay so
here's the here's what's going on so
from the first tiny guns there's a shot
where a guy gets shot in the face and
his brain falls out of his head onto the
hood of a car that wasn't a planned shot
we gave the shot to peter france and he
took it into blender and he spent like a
week or so on it and he gave us the shot
back we were like oh my god like the
guy's brain fell out peter what are you
doing you've you've lost your mind we
realized though that that's like kind of
the core of this video these tiny little
guns that shoot baby size bullets but
when they hit it's like getting hit with
a missile we took that as our vision and
the direction for the second video which
we're shooting down in san antonio texas
with our friends at black rifle coffee
i've been experimenting with a really
cool explosion physics plug-in called x
particles in anticipation for this video
and hopefully it doesn't get demonetized
hopefully well hold up i genuinely hope
it doesn't get demonetized but i would
really like to push the limits and see
how far we can take this before getting
demonetized we've only had one video on
our channel get demonetized because of
violence it was the slow motion headshot
fallout video that was filmed all live
action so i'm hoping maybe we get a
little pass because this is cg although
this is a little bit more offensive in
its uh context so to speak because it's
suicide bombers it's war and knowing the
black rifle copy guys well they have a
pretty extreme sense of humor to say the
least which is perfect for this video
there's a line out there somewhere that
divides where youtube monetization
begins and ends
hopefully with this video we find it
[Music]
howdy y'all
came all the way out here to good old
texas so we could uh bag ourselves some
sand i hear the sand is better out here
it's more dense well you see we came on
out here because uh the boys want to
shoot a video but all i know is that
there's some kind of checkpoint it's
real important that this checkpoint look
sort of official militaria we got up
here sells here a bunch of sandbags and
some camo nets and some cardboard boxes
and i guess that's the hollywood way of
doing uh official militaria and then
we're gonna put a couple actors in there
and we're gonna shoot a whole scene
called tiny guns too
[Music]
you gotta eat your brisket i need to
earn my lunch the villager didn't stop
digging this villager is a cgi video
game character we'll all be pixels one
day
we will all be pixels one day
this looks legit dude filled boxes with
dirt wrap them in chicken wire
covered it with camo netting
it does look a little janky because it
is but when you film it on camera shoot
it cinematically i think it's gonna look
pretty natural
ah
i'm done
[Music]
i got the 50 today my bipods work which
is pretty cool
[Music]
look at what they built yesterday
on a sunday most people are off not them
they were actually building all this and
it looks
damn legit for some chicken wire and
cardboard boxes it almost looks like a
fob so how many times did you stand
security a tower guard once in missoula
those guys actually endure a lot i would
hate to be in a car and i'm not being
facetious whatsoever just waiting to get
ied'ed or mortared no thanks cheers to
you guys
okey-dokey action
it's a suicide bomber open fire
[Music]
now
where do you want it
we're gonna film this looking realistic
at all i don't know we'll figure it out
i can't pride everything that i do once
in a while i want my private space this
guy's got the chatter we got an inbound
polo
perfect
[Laughter]
that is some great a cinema digging for
soft dirt so we can throw it at eli and
matt we don't have any real explosives
on set today we got to simulate
leftovers of an explosion dirt flying
all over the place you want dirt in this
one yeah
[Music]
so cinematic buddy
i'm doing a silly shot now this gimbal
is a rotation mode so i've always wanted
to mess around with it i think we have a
cool shot here where these uh two guys
are rolling around on the ground with a
knife so i'm gonna have the camera
spinning with them maybe you'll look
cool who knows not trying to be all rc
footsie here but you know
[Music]
[Applause]
all right everyone raise your hands as
if you have detonators rolling
action
this is how you make 10 terrorists out
of three the way to get around only
having three tears is the core doorway
slight costume changes after these three
die maybe throw on a different vest
maybe throw on a different color
headband even just the slightest change
makes it look like a different person so
if they're not main characters they're
basically just this body's dying and
with the kind of comps and the angles
it'll look like multiple guys are coming
at the same time do you like my fall
fashion look autumn jihad autumn jihad
man you know what makes a lot of sense
fighting terrorists for 15 years of my
life only to be dressing up as one that
video you guys did with the with freddie
recently like you're shooting some
people in the face and you don't get
demonetized like why the [ __ ] are they
up our ass so much it's because they're
clowns they're clowns
they call me
you know big habib
the key to looking like a terrorist is
your clothes not fitting and being kind
of fat hold this right there
it looks so
dumb
i'm about to send all you infinites to
mukalla are you sir bro
we're kind of echoing that monty python
like infinite run where you're just
constantly running there's gonna be a
lot of running here you'll get your
cardio for the day just hold like hold
the phone
up like that yeah yeah exactly because
action jt
it's so dumb just like so far away this
is so ineffectively far away
matt
i'm just taking a nap bronson showing
five minutes
but okay
you're okay yeah i'm great
this is it this is the last sequence
it's hot everyone's a little tired we're
racing the sun we probably have
an hour and a half
you really missed because we just got to
get through it all we can get out of
here it's time to move we are setting up
a forced perspective shot basically a
shot where the crew will tower over my
character general groskowski here boys
time to man up
how is the fighting take the day off the
way we're gonna make me look small is
basically i'm just gonna be walking into
the distance away from camera and acting
in my own little plate and that way from
the camera's perspective it looks like
i'm actually really tiny
is everybody all right i heard you guys
were in some big trouble well general
it's a little too early to tell but i
heard we're going to be huge war heroes
wow congratulations you know what take
the rest of the day off you earned it
all right cool that's that that's it
rap on
stolen
valor see you in hell you sons of
[ __ ]
in this video there's like about seven
or eight suicide bombers who get shot
with a sniper rifle and then blow up and
so i've kind of created a suicide bomber
explosion assembly line here where all i
need to do is i drop my shot into my
file a few things with my mouse and then
after that everything's done and i think
i'm finally there at this point so i
import my footage i create a very
rudimentary 3d model of the person
blowing up and once it's plugged into
the rest of the systems it just
functions there's a lot of 3d
simulations happening i've got a fire
explosion simulation that's happening i
have a gooey gut chunk past basically
i'm going to fill this thing up with jam
some strawberry jam i have a cloth
tearing and shredding simulation i
basically have a master file that i've
created that has all my settings in it
and all i have to do is basically drop
my footage in there i just hit a couple
buttons and it simulates and it all just
works it looks pretty good it took me
about three months to kind of get to
this point ever since we filmed this
video in november i've been kind of
working on this little assembly line in
the background nailing the perfect 3d
simulated explosion has always been one
of my main goals because when you have a
full 3d explosion like this you have so
much control you can have something blow
up and you can animate something flying
through and all the smoke reacts to it
but it's just like it's so powerful to
be able to do this so i'm glad i spent
the time on this explosions are just fun
to watch because they're very
they're powerful
moments they're complex moments there's
a lot going on we've been obsessed with
pyrotechnics forever and while we can't
go outside and blow things up with
gasoline we can come in here on our
computers and basically do the same
thing and it's that same satisfying
punch
and so yeah having full control over
this kind of stuff here it's so powerful
and it's just it's a great feeling
[Music]
oh god it looks like so lightheaded i
just was screaming for like a half hour
doing terrorist vocals in the style of
team america der kadurka muhammad jihad
not in the style of any real life person
any relationship to any people in real
life is completely a coincidence it's
just gibberish no offense
wow i might joke that it would be funny
to get this video demonetized i have
i have no idea because it's really
cartoony you know it's super offensive
but it's it's also a joke so jokes can
be offensive
right
it's a suicide bomber
open fire
get the goddamn air force send
reinforcements now
[Music]
[Music]
hey if you guys aren't subscribed go
ahead and click that subscribe button
also there's a notification bell you're
going to want to ring that leave a
comment down below if you have any
questions or uh suggestions
if you're on the toilet leave a comment
saying you're not on the toilet